Kottbusser Tor das türkische Herz der
Hauptstadt und auch problemecke Drogen
Gewalt Abend kommen die Leute her die
setzen sich hier manchmal sind bis zu 6
S sogar ze Leute die trinken hier die
nehmen sich Drogen letztens haben wir
mit meiner Nachbarin hier auf den
Treppen wieder Spritzen gesehen dabei
gibt es hier seit Anfang des Jahres eine
nebenwache der Polizei täglich gehen sie
auf
aber die Einsatzkräfte in Berlin am
Limit vermehrt tauchen am kotbuser Tor
Delikte der Drogenkriminalität auf
Rohheitsdelikte wie
Körperverletzung und diebstahlstaten wie
taschendiebstellele dennoch lieben die
Anwohner ihren Kotti wie sie das
cotbusser Tour nennen wir treffen einige
von
ihnen
erul ist seit Jahrzehnten am kotbusser
Tour unterwegs betreibt hier ein Kaffee
er sagt durch die Polizeiwache habe sich
einiges verändert auch zum
Guten gefallen und dann Diebstahl die
sind nicht mehr absuerei antranzerei die
sind alles verbesser ist nur
Drogenhandel ist noch immer noch er
nennen sie Papa Kotti weil er fast jeden
kennt er sagt für ihn ist das hier wie
ein Dorf tatsächlich sind auf dem Platz
die Dealer verschwunden und die
Süchtigen abge in die Nebenstraßen und
vor tuis gölmit
dönerlagen wenn jetzt vor der Tür was
passiert diese streiten wegen Drohung
oder sonst was passiert auch schon mal
dass sie sich gegenseitig schlagen dass
Polizeieinsatz kommt oder
dass jetzt keine Passanten meistens Hal
sie selber sich verletzen aber trotzdem
besteht da auch eine gewisse Gefahr dass
Passanten dabei auch verletzt wden auch
vor diesem Haus nah dem Kotti lungern
oft Dealer und abhängige herum in tusan
wohnt
hier Abend kommen die Leute her die
setzen sich hier manchmal sind bis zu 6
S sogar Zeh Leute die trinken hier die
nehmen sich Drogen ich bin nicht der
einzige der hier wohnt sind Familien und
Kinder die fühlen sich natürlich nicht
sicher dabei ist die Polizei hier jeden
Tag jede Nacht unterwegs am kottisin
Drogendealer geben zivilfahrender Ihnen
per Walkie-Talkie durch zwei Männer
verschwinden eilig in einer Nebenstraße
die Faher sind ihnen auf der
Spur stellen und durchsuchen die
vermeintlichen
Täter wir haben jetzt hier gerade eine
Überprüfung zon zwei männlichen Personen
die sich vorher am Brennpunkt Kotti
aufgehalten haben und die werden jetzt
erstmal überprüft vermehrt tauchen am
kotbusser Tor Delikte der
Drogenkriminalität auf Rohheitsdelikte
wie
Körperverletzung und diebstahlstaten wie
Taschen diebstelle das kommt unter
anderem zustande weil wir hier einen
sehr großen Umsteigebahnhof haben all
dies bleiben aber nur Nadelstiche in
Berlin ein der Stadt deren Polizei am
Limit ist auch durch den Krieg in narost
und der vielen Demonstrationen deshalb
na grundsätzlich ist so dass uns einfach
viele Kräfte die sonst an den Einsätzen
hier beteiligt sind entzogen werden weil
die stadtweit halt andere Maßnahmen
fahren müssen sei es na Ost seines
klimakleber von daher haben wir weniger
Kräfte zur Verfügung nichtdestotrotz
haben wir immer noch eine hohe Anzahl an
Einlieferung und Vollstreckung von
Haftbefehl
das läuft ganz
gut durch die neue Polizeiwache am Kotti
können Tatverdächtige schneller
überprüft werden Anwohner fühlen sich
ein wenig sicherer insgesamt wurde die
Wache nach anfänglichen Bedenken gut
angenommen ich glaube das hat sich
etabliert als Ansprechpunkt für die
Bürger jetzt nicht unbedingt auch nur um
Strafanzeigen zu stellen sondern dass
die Polizei bürgernah Auftritt
niedrigschwellig quasi ein Angebot
bietet ich glaube die Akzeptanz hier
insgesamt am kotbusser Tor für die Wache
ist sehr gestiegen ich glaube da gab es
sehr viel Misskredit am Anfang der jetzt
aber ausgeräumt wurde und von daher
glaube ich man hat hier mittlerweile ein
gesundes eine gesunde Zusammenarbeit
etabliert dies bestätigen auch die
Frauen im türkischen Treff wie erdan
leben sie seit Jahren am Cottbusser Tor
lieben ihre Gemeinschaft alle wünschen
sich noch mehr Einsätze der Polizei zwar
gebe es keine sexuellen Übergriffe mehr
der Drogenkonsum Dealer und fixer sind
für die Frauen und ihre Kinder nach wie
unerträglich letztens haben wir mit
meiner Nachbarin hier auf den Treppen
wieder Spritzen gesehen mit Blut und
unsere Kinder gehen ja hier die Treppen
hoch runter zum Spielplatz mit den
Drogen das haben wir denn irgendwie es
ist jetzt nicht viel besser ist es nicht
dadurch geworden finde
ich es ist es müsste natürlich die ganze
das ganze Problem im Haus fängt ja denn
an also ich kann nicht sagen dass da
halt sich vieles geändert hat aber es
gibt eben auch diese andere Seite vom
Kotti das Miteinander der Menschen hier
das dörfliche eran besucht seinen Freund
Avni Kani ihm gehört ein kleines
Fischrestaurant die beiden kennen sich
seit fast drei Jahrzehnten auch für Avni
und seine Familie ist der Kotti in all
der langen Zeit Heimat geworden die
Spezialität hier Fischsuppe mit lach ich
bin ein Jahre hier mit meiner Familie
und alles also meine Brot auch hier ist
wo soll gehen in der Küche helfen Avni
und seine Frau mukates noch immer aber
eigentlich übernimmt Sohn Sedat nach und
nach das Geschäft die Kundschaft sagt er
verändere sich stetig in den letzten
Jahren kämen auch immer mehr Touristen
unser Stamm also unsere stammfunten sind
auch die meisten Türken aber wir haben
auch sehr viele Deutsche und Touristen
eigentlich alles denn Kreuzberg wandelt
sich wird immer teurer und schicker
erjan selbst betreibt am Kotti direkt
neben der Polizeiwache ein
traditionskaffee seit 16 Jahren hier ist
Kreuzberg noch wie einst überall
multikulturell gemütlich ein wenig
verlebt der Kaffee günstig wie lange die
so bleiben kann weiß auch er nicht denn
neben den Drogenproblemen steigen die
Mieten ständig viele mussten den Kotti
schon verlassen K sehr
schnelländern diese Mietpreise diese
wohnungmetpreise und ladenmetpreise so
schnell hochsteigen dass in Z D Jahren
werde ich Rente sein und ich kann diese
Miete nicht mehr zahlen auf dem Stelle
kommen die Marken und diese Marken
werden internationale Marken sein was so
se ändert das
Publikum Kunde es ktiv wir total anders
da sein dann muss wohl auch erjan
wegziehen ein Stück seines Herzens aber
so sagt der wird bleiben am Kottbusser
Tor seinem Dorf trotz all der
Probleme